okay
hi everyone welcome
my name is omar sanseviero i am a ml
engineer at hooking face and i'm very
excited to be hosting this event
today we are welcoming the diet nerf
team from the jax flex event
that we held a couple of months ago
so you will hear all about it in a
couple of minutes so i won't say much
but this team was able to implement diet
nerve injects which is a very nice model
that is able to reconstruct 3d scenes
with just a couple of views so that
means that from an from a couple of
images from different angles they are
able to reconstruct 3d scenes so it's
super interesting
as a reminder you can join in twitch
youtube and linkedin we also welcome you
to our discord server to the general
event chat room channel and ask
questions there as well
so i will be keeping an eye there if
people have any questions
and if you don't know what's the link to
this card you can see below in the
banner
so let me introduce the speakers for
this talk
we have a stella jang
she is a phd candidate at the seoul
national university
she does research about nerve scene
generation three division and visual
localization
so welcome er we also have saint john
he is a phd candidate at the inha
university
his research areas are computer vision
machine learning and neural network
light weighting
and finally there's a there's also alex
love
he currently works at the ai software
sorry as an ai software engineer in
defense in pension in singapore
so having said that please let's give a
peer-to-peer applause to the speakers
and thanks a lot for joining i'll leave
you up to it
welcome
yeah thank you for a nice introduction
for omar and let's start our
presentation
hello everyone thank you for coming our
hugging face talk my name is soya yang
and this is our team of who we present
today
yes we will introduce our implementation
of diet nerve with jackson flex
today's presentation agent that is
followed
for computer vision field the
3d vision is neutralizing field in these
days
you can find the tremendous papers are
coming on the many conferences
and
this graph shows the 3d is the one of
the hot topic for the computer vision
research
the reason why the computer vision is
popular is
maybe
it have many application industry field
which is growing fast faster
among three divisions there are some new
syndrome of the nerve
after the vanilla nerve paper is coming
a lot of nerve variant papers are
submitted
this speed beyond the pace of gins
popularity
and almost 534
paper
is
yeah
usds nerf paper
if we look for the cause of this
syndrome i think it has to do with the
recent metabolic strength
in the metabolism the law of creating 3d
object creating apertures and generating
scenes will become very important so
these future prospects increase the
interest of the nerve and occurred the
explosion of the nerve research
now let's look at the structure of
nerves one by one
therapy is actually just a multi-layer
perceptron which can encode the syn
slading sphere
the input of the nerve is the 3d
coordinate pose which is the 3d location
and 2d viewing directions
also the output is emitted color and
volume density
the training process is follows
at first we sampled the 5d coordinate
among camera lens and next feeding those
locations into an mrp to produce a color
and volume density
after that using volume rendering
techniques to compose
these various into an image
this landing function is differentiable
so finally we can optimize our scene
representation by minimizing the
residual
between synthesize and ground
truth-observed image
the nerve render the color of any lane
lay passing through the scene using
principles from classical volume
rendering
to explain the volume rendering process
you can check this integral formula
the function t denotes the accumulated
transmittance along the lay from tn
to tf
the tn and tf is the lace
near and far bound
the limits of integral
the volume density
delta can
be interpreted as the differential
probability of a lathe
terminating at an infinitesimal particle
at location
r
the term c means the total radiance
light
that the point at t of r
stands in the direction d
nerve numerically estimates this
continuous integral using quadrature
deterministic quadrature which is
typically used for rendering
this discretized volume boxer grid
would effectively limit our
representations resolutions
because the mrp would only be queried at
a fixed discrete set of locations
it used a stratified sampling approach
where we partitioned tn to tf into n
ebrines based beans
and
then draw one sample uniformly and
random
from within each bin
and use these samples to estimate c
color with the quadratic
quadrature rule
use reading deemed learning network are
biased toward loading lower frequency
functions
so the mapping the input to a higher
dimensional space using higher frequency
function
before passing them to the network
enable better fitting of data that
contains high frequency variant
gamma is a mapping function from r
into a high dimensional space
our power to error
which is not trainable it is just a
positional encoding function and
uh given some hyperparameter
this is also can be found on the famous
model transformer architecture
our rendering strategy at every end
quarry points along each camellia is
inefficient
so to optimize a neural admin sphere uh
nerves use some highlighter volume
sampling
in first
course space
nerf use
nerf samples a small number of points
and c
using the name stratified sampling
this path will tell us the region where
good point lies
in the second fine path
we will treat normalized weight
this normalized way produce a piecewise
constant pdf along the lake
evaluate our fine network at the union
of the first and second set of samples
and compute the final rendering rendered
color of the lay sea
the nerve structure was
suggested and the result is shown here
to evaluate nerve motor the other
compare against current type performing
techniques for biosynthesis
nerve can be able to recover fine
details in both geometry and appearance
you can check this
leisure video quality
yeah you can check it in the nerve uh
official pace so if you're interested in
please visit
yeah after the binaural nerve there are
many variants of nerve is coming
if nip is nice quality the impulse was
not real time speed so there are some
work to deal this problem
play not trees use the oak tree
structure to speed up the geometry query
and
baking neural fields use a slightly
different data structure to save the
explicit geometry
and last a kill kill owner proposed the
the comp decompose this large deep
network into a set of small shallow
network
that captures only a small portion of
the space and make a much faster network
moreover the nerve has a limitation
as a
slow training speed
so it needs too much training time for
only one scene
some work of attempt to find the general
nerve that can quickly transfer to all
scenes
for example the pixel nerve introducing
an architecture that conditions a nerve
on image input in a very convolutional
manner
this allowed the network to be trained
across multiple scenes to learn a scene
prior
also mbs nerf using some multi-view
geometry knowledge and used cost volume
concept
also our project diet nerve use 70
consistency loss using 2d to 3d
supervision as a prior notice
at last some metallic approach is done
and finding some generalizable initial
weight for nerve
besides some effort focus on dynamic and
articulate tissue
nullified the form of deformed spdo
using a second mrp applying a
deformation for each frame of video
animate turbulent nerve use a tract
skeleton from mocap data and multiview
video to train skeleton-based blind
blend fields that then transform the
latin sphere enabling
skeleton-driving synthesis of peoples of
avatar
because the nerve needs some position
lover and camera intricacy parameters
so like eye nerve and surf calibration
nerve
they try to find the camera information
also there are further attempts such as
imap which apply it to slam
some nerve bearing try to decompose the
nerve
geometry appearance and position
transformation components in the scene
giraffe and giraffe
and added nerve show this decomposition
decompositional control is possible
in nerve scan
at last example several research was
conducted to create a moral natural
synthesis seen view with nerve
can craft transforms the minecraft
blocked structure into realist scenes
and style nerves synthesize a very
natural 3d phase from multiple angles
yeah this is introduction of nerve
variance and
as tera explained surface very powerful
tool to render the 3d object but it
still has a limitation
then nerf often often fails to
synthesize an overview when trained on
limited data
here with hundreds of views the earth
resists like hot dog in every viewpoint
it looks clear and there are no standing
out artifacts
however with abuse the objective is
jitters and in some cases they're
completely fair to render
to solve this problem iron nervous
proposed the name is a diode of the
training data set
in a nutshell to list the quantity of
the training data set direct injects
symmetric consistency constraints making
a hot dog like a hot dog in every
direction
before discussing
diet nerve let me first explain the
reason why nerve has this problem
the authors of dire nerve argue that
nerve has these three problems
overfitting regularization and no prior
knowledge
first the nerve is very easy to office
rurfi is trained on a trend to estimate
rgb value from corresponding rays
at this time
there are no special constraints and if
the data set is limited nerf is easily
refitted to the same post
when therefore
office to train a post it cannot be
generalized to the unseen area that is
an area that no camera has seen
as shown in this figure
when only the right side of the lego is
visible the left area is not rendered
either
it is because this region has not been
trained and it almost depends on
random initialization
the most intuitive and widely known way
to solve our fitting is to reduce the
network capacity and apply
regularization
accordingly they also supply the
following regularization tricks to see
whether the problem is reserved or not
you can see that simplified nerve has a
clear performance improvement in the
unseen area
however the artifacts are still severe
and in the same area the purpose is
degraded
in other words simple regularization
cannot completely completely solve the
overfitting problem of nerve
the authors argue that this problem is
caused by a lack of prior knowledge
nerf is learning without any cementing
information which means that the earth
renders objects without understanding
what it is
therefore to make nerves generalized to
unseen views they also stood that the
estimated information should be injected
as the prior knowledge
the author's proposed dialogue the
investigating information to nerve
by applying constraints to ensure high
symmetry consistency
iron nerve can render on stream views
without compromising details
the concept of dial nerf is very simple
similar information of the object is
extracted from the known views using a
pre-trained network such as cliff vit
then direct minimize the symmetric
difference between the unknown views and
the render speeds rendered views
the known views are drawn from train set
and the rendered view are randomly
sampled so that they are number
as i mentioned earlier this concept is
to have the same symmetry information as
the scene view with an interview
in other words a leg in other words our
lego should look like a lego in any pose
experimentally just show that dire nerf
renders unseen views where without
compromising details of slim view
it's still not perfect but if you
compare it to nerf you can see that
there is a vast improvement
so next before we going through the
implementation details so we would like
to give an introduction to jax firstly
because we mainly implement injects in
our model also secondly
i believe some of the audience may hear
a lot about jax that may not have some
hands-on experience on it
so essentially what is jax jax is a
framework designed by google research
for high performance numerical computing
so to me i think jax has three core
features firstly it has a numpy like uh
interface
secondly is code can be easily
accelerated on
a different devices such as cpu gpu and
tpu
and also uh
one key feature i would like to
highlight is the composable function
transformation so actually by the first
time i look at this term i really don't
know what it is so i would like to take
this chance to take a little bit on what
it is and briefly how does it work
so what is composable function
transformation essentially you can think
of it as a transformation to transform a
python function to another python
function
the purpose is to extend its original
functionality or change the
functionality for example the feed the
feed map pmap jit or grant
is some of the example of function
transformation that is offered by jax
framework
so uh it is called composable because uh
the return of this kind of
transformation is another new python
function so you know with this new
pattern function you can apply another
round of function transformation again
so that's why it is called composable
so no matter what kind of uh function
transformation you're going to apply
there are some common steps that is
undergo that is performed underneath the
hood injects
so you may wonder by the time
the user let's say define a function
let's call log2
what is happening underneath the hood
when we apply a function transformation
on log2 let's say we apply a jit on it
just send for just in time compilation
which i will explain later so what is
happening underneath the hood is that
firstly is trying to
uh jax is trying to trace the operation
that is performed in this function it is
trying to wrap the function input which
is x in this case by a tracer object in
this case chaser object is called shape
value shape array sorry so this shape
array will keep track of the
dimension the shape of the input and
also the type of the input
and then uh the jacks will step through
each line of the function in order to
record
each operation that is applied on this
tracer input
so once you have
record this kind of input what you can
do is you can reconstruct the whole
function in
with a
so called a intermediate representation
so this intermediate representation is
shown on your right hand side in purple
color
so this
intermediate representation is called
jax per essentially it's trying to
encode the primitive operation which is
some elementary operation like
logarithmic
and division
of this function and try to encode that
and represent it
so once you have this uh
intermediate transformation right
you will see that at the center we
already get a intermediate
representation
from
the user defined function transformation
on the right left hand side so once you
have this intermediate representation
you can achieve many parameters
so what jack's doing is with this with
this code
they will use a jack interpreter to
reinterpret this code into different
purposes
for example you can use this
intermediate representation to transform
it into another new python function we
can do auto factorization which is what
vm do
on the other hand you can also
transform it in a way that you can
support parallelism to run across
different tpu cores this is what pmap is
doing
on the other hand you can also transform
it in a way that it can support the
first derivative this is what graph is
doing
meanwhile you can also apply the just in
time compilation on it
so to give more details on it what you
are what it is essentially doing is that
by the time you wrap the function by jit
it will reconstruct the code into
something like
a high level optimized code set for
hello
and then this high level optimized code
will serve as an input to a compiler
which is called xla the xla stands for
accelerated linear algebra
compiler essentially what it does is
it's trying to interpret the whole
operation of this function and then try
to come up with some
optimization for it to fill some of the
computation you know so as to speed up
and then what it will return is
essentially a domain specific compile
code
this domain-specific compile code means
that
the code is specific to different device
tpu gpu or cpu so that the user only
need to define
the code on the left-hand side and the
chest will do the rest for you
so as for flex is another framework that
we use it is a deep learning framework
that is built on top of jacks so it
provides a pretty nice interface for us
to define the models and optimizer
so these two examples are the optimum
example for the model definition for
convolutional network and also the
definite and also how we define the
state
uh here we define the model also need to
define the weight parameters together
with the optimizer then we will wrap
this by a trend train state
so i believe some of the audience may
wonder what is the difference between
jacks and other popular deep learning
frameworks such as tensorflow and pi
torch
so from my experience i can name a few
and they are categorized by pros and
cons so first we start with pros i think
that uh for the jax it can be easily run
on
different devices without any code
change so i would say it's pretty easy
to use for different devices
meanwhile is also applicable to many
domain as well so in tensorflow and
python i believe they mainly use in
probabilistic
programming or deep learning but in jax
not only it can be applied on
differentiation optimization it can be
used in some data preprocessing as well
and also using simulation i do see some
examples from twitter
they are trying to apply the jacks in
data augmentation and essentially just
trying to augment the image using the
tpu cores distributed nicely so that you
can gain a significant speed up
so meanwhile since it is numpy like
interface i believe this interface is
super easy to use for most of the user
who are get used to numpy or scipy
also it has a pretty flexible control on
the parallelism so it is very beneficial
for you to do large-scale computing
in the sense that you can nicely control
in
in what kind of dimension in what kind
of area you want to distribute your
compute across different tpu cores
so
right now jax has a p-map to support
that on top of that it also has a beta
features which i recently seen in the
documentation which is called xmap
and on the other hand is empirically
i see that it's generally run faster
than other framework
but undeniably it also have some uh
um limitation as well one of the
uh major limitations from my experience
is that it will give you some unexpected
outcome if you are trying to apply your
function transformation improperly
essentially if your function has some
side effect for example you have a print
statement in it or you insert a global
variable in it
these
the jets cannot
correctly interpret this so as a result
you will get out some unexpected outcome
without any warning so this is something
you need to pay attention
on the other hand i would say jax is a
pretty new language so i would say it
takes some time to build up the whole
ecosystem i mean is associated high
level frameworks
so here is just some
screenshots showing the performance
objects comparing tensorflow and pycharg
and you can see that in general in some
cases for example in transformer and
also resnet it is uh
it is training is training faster than
other frameworks
so finally if you want to know more jax
and flex we do have some resources
attached here we have some youtube talk
uh particularly i will highlight the
second one essentially it's a talk uh
hold by
uh jake fender plus he's a
he's a google developer who is
developing
jax he gives a really nice introduction
to jax
and also you can quickly go into the
jackson flex documentation also
we also have a stud i also noticed
there's a study group organized by wix
and bias uh sam bhutani will uh will
walk us through uh the jacks we'll study
the checks together with the audience so
it just organized recently so i would
highly recommend to join this if you
want to know more about checks
okay now i will explain how we have
implemented dial nerve
but first you should note that our
implementation is not exactly the same
because of some unspecified hyper
parameters and lack of our jack skin
there nevertheless our implementation
seems to work quite well and can
reproduce most of the results the others
have reported in the paper
therefore if you have enough jsk you can
get better results based on our
implementation
there are three core parts for
implementing dim learning algorithms
data provider letter and objective
function
the overall algorithm is shown here
arcade lines indicate diuner things and
others indicate nerf things
as i said it looks straightforward
prepare semantic information using scene
view random images from the london post
is to estimate information and mean and
minimize a difference with information
from thingview
here since the network is the same as
nurse our main task only was to
implement the other two parts data
provider and objective function
it sounds easy so we underestimate that
these are not very difficult tasks
but they are they are not they were not
because of some problems
let me explain them step by
step the first part is the data provider
fortunately the pre-trained cliff vit
model is already in the flex library
also it is very much easy to use
one line is enough to load it the only
thing we had to do was implement a
pre-processing algorithm for cliff vit
by the text library
this pre-processing is well known
imagine normalization
and here we can specify the data type of
cliff vit
as we will be explained later
we need to reduce the memory cost of
diameter parts half christian is
utilized to create vit therefore
one more important thing that i want to
inform you is this code look like a
numpy code
if you refresh jmp into mp most of code
view works well except for jax imagery
size
there is tf image resize in tensorflow
in this there are so many test pro like
things such as jsscon jss while loop and
jack's left slides
to me jackson language looking like a
combination of numpy and test flow
you know that jax is developed by google
azure
so if you are tensorflow user you can
learn js quieter
back to the data provider the next step
is generating the random pose a render
post can be easily implemented by
picking one post as the default and
implementing others
for other posts as its rotation
the realistic synthetic data set we used
in this project
this is the upper hemisphere
therefore our post boundary is expressed
as shown in this figure
if you know about spherical coordinates
this representation might look a bit
weird
in general spherical coordinates phi
does not go from bottom to top but from
top to bottom which means the north pole
is zero degree
however we thought that this might seem
rather strange to demo users so to make
it user friendly we reverse the phi
coordinates and set the front view as
the difference that means zero degree
as a result zeta has a boundary from
minus pi to pi and phi
has a boundary from 0 to pi over 2.
for radius the dataset boundary was used
as it is
unlike most of code used here you are
probably not familiar with jack's random
split
just land of split is a function that
generates a length of seed
it receives rng and returns orange again
and rng input which is a land of seed
therefore if only the first length of c
is determined we can easily generate a
sequence of random variables to perform
pseudo random number generation
since random sheet contour is one of the
important parts of
it is quite beneficial to suffer these
functions relatively
the next step is to generate lasers
generate lays according to a random post
in the realistic synthesis data set
image resolution is 800 by 800 and it is
usually sampled to be 400 by 400.
both are too large and will consume too
much gpu memory so the others utilized
utilized three tricks to reduce cost
the first is cross sampling
they also approached that they used a
large sampling stride and used only
about 15 percent to the number of relays
it's kind of weird why the authors
didn't mention the specific stride but
they would have used a stride greater
than 2 anyway and fewer less than 400 by
400.
the second is mixed pristine
the authors use single prism for nerf
and half physician for running cement
information
then the additional memory cost can be
reduced by half through
and it can be applied easily by denoting
the data type of race and network
the last is deleting and rematerializing
equation
this trick has kept
as many teslas as needed on the gpu and
the less detached
which makes the number of tensors on the
gpu minimize
however jax doesn't natively support it
jeff focuses on setting mode for a jig
compiling which is not available on this
kind of trick
even though we dropped the compiling it
would be quite tough to implement this
training process
we were almost on uv of jackson flex
when we started this project
so we had to skip this trick but the
problem was that the memory cost
increased dramatically
since the network could not be changed
we have to find a way to reach the
memory cost further while still
delivering symmetric information
we first checked the maximum number of
relays that could be loaded to our
hardware
and it was 75 by 75
this was less than one percent of the
original meat originally
if we use this resolution the earth can
see the shape of the shape of the object
but cannot know the fine details at all
this figure is a lego producer sampled
at 75 by 75 slides
a producer is recognizable but details
like a lego bump are very thin
in order to solve this problem we first
reduce the image size through the render
through the render clock
then we set the sampling rate to 4 to
get as many rays as our gpu can handle
as described before our data provider
samples various radiuses
so
with the new sampling strategy
some images show the overall shape as
shown in this figure and some others
should find details as shown in this
figure as well
therefore we expected that the purpose
improvement achieved by dire nerf would
be reproduced with this scheme
surely it would be better to use our
lace but most of the implementation
implement experimental issues come from
the our
nerve has higher purpose than nerve
the implemented code is shown in
direction on the right
the first thing i want to note that is
the treatment
treatment applies the given function to
the leaves in the nested list
it's not very special but it makes
coding easier and clearer
and the chart distributes distributes
the data as many as number of gpus for
distributing
it simply has the form of a numpy
reshape and it is implemented through
streaming as well
finally data for running lender post is
prepared by specifying the data type as
hub friction
next i will explain the training step
for running semantic consistency
earlier i said that this process was
just formed by a nerve
it was nearly 2
however during the implementation we
discovered that the code for single and
multi-gpus has to be different
accordingly we first separate the train
step of nerve and the semantic
consistency training step
and following the lazy regulations
concept
we
which is often
used in gain
semantic constraints are delivered at
regular intervals
on the green line the data provider
prepares the training data and decides
which training step to use based on the
number of
devices in the green box
first i will explain the single gpu
version
because nerf uses two dimensional
batteries that is batch rays we reshape
the rays first
and apply it to the motor to render the
image
next convert the rendered image back to
a three-dimensional tensor and put it
into clip to get embedded features
finally
dial nerf is trained to minimize the
difference with the with the emitted
feature of the scene view
the cementing loss function is good
value and grad and the gradient is
calculated
the training variables of nerve are
denoted on the group line
and their gradients are completed by
autograd
this process should be familiar to
tensorflow to users
this is because this area
operates in almost the same concept as
the gradient state
even if you are a python user i think
this structure is not difficult to
understand
but the problem occurred when we
expanded this training roof to virtual
gpu
as soon in this figure
when multiple gpus are used laser
distributed to each gpu
if the model we run is typical nerf the
implementation is finished here and the
training roof runs without any problems
however
we cannot put two distributed
images in clip
in other words distributed images should
be put into clips after combining them
to become one whole image again
i'm not i'm not a python user so i don't
know the case in pythons or tensorflow
requires a lot of code to implement this
kind of flexible communication between
gps
however that makes this process
relatively easy
now the earthling clip are defined
through different functions because they
operate in different gpu environment
the rendering function applies p map
like the existing training step
p main the input function works on
multiple gpus at multiple devices as
alex explained
on the other hand as i mentioned earlier
images for clips should not be
distributed
therefore you can see that the ig values
obtained through the render function is
uncharted and all located on
one gpu
on chart is now a special function it
simply makes two images into one using
tensory shape
in other words communication between gps
and decks is very flexible and can be
implemented more easily than
testosterone or pythos
that's it for our implementation of
diamond earth there are some imperfect
parts but it was great great opportunity
to practice on x
in particular as you can see on previous
page
you you can see the automatic objects
over tensorflow and pythons
yeah sunyang explained our
implementation well
and next i want to introduce
the story of our sprint journey
uh yeah it is a funny story yeah our
first journey began when i found the
hugging face jack flax spring post on
facebook
at the time i desire to study about the
nerd
checks
because jax cs famously used the nerve
to increase the performance
so i thought this contest is a really
good opportunity
after talking with my friend
jeong
we make a team and
we like the proposal
for diet nerve
there were many natural language teams
but i suggest the diet nerve because it
used the creep model
team
team began to liquidate on the bretton
board and finally the global team is
composed with 10 people
our team is consist of five
south korean one hong kong
to indian one bangladesh
community communication with many uh
country people was really hurt and we
need to find some efficient
communication strategy
so we created a notion dashboard and
specifically divide the team as nerve
team creep team and crowd team
we allocate our work equally and
efficiently to these three teams
also i try to clarify the
git branch
name and create some github issue to
deal the multiple errors
moreover hugging face and google cloud
gave us a useful talk about jax flex and
transformers
so we could learn a lot about jack's
grammars and newspapers
and some platforms like uh space and
hugging pace hub etc and one db and
support us
also our mentor patrick and surat and
many uh
organizers gives some a good operation
and they
especially our mentor resources
give us some code code review and it
becomes a great tariff
luckily we become the top 15.
our hugging face mentors gave us a very
detailed living leopard
and with this feedback we laced for the
final top three
from that day on we stayed up all night
with coding
because of our lack of research our team
but many core pros account for this
competition uh
in my case i bought a
full correct pro account for this
competition and spend a lot of money
but it is okay
yeah
at such a difficult moment i asked it
i asked it uh in the facebook post
is there anyone who could lend me a more
collab pro account
and so
if at the post uh
binhan who is the ceo of
common computer company he want to
sponsor us
yeah so he lent a full we
we 100 gpu unit for us
it was uh
like a meeting uh angel for us
thank you so much common computer
finally we make it into the top three
i was really proud and happy for this
yeah
competition
thank you for our nice team who work
hard day and night and i think it's
because we did a great job of
visualizing our research on space and
some broad posts
alex liked a nice broadcast with hassan
yeah
also
when we post this
winning news on our twitter
the order of diet nerve
as a
aj jane uh praised us with like and
messes
and the famous professor peter abir also
hit the like button i am really friend
for him yeah especially
omar attacked us
in twitter post uh some people related
to nerf and it was really helpful so
thank you so much omar
yeah
so finally we would like to cherry-pick
some of the
experimental results
uh
so the first set result is that we are
trying to train
the lego scene and also the ship scene
on 14 samples but these following
samples are biased on one side only
as you can see the lego only shown on
one side and the ship is also only shown
for on one side
so what we get at the end if you look at
right hand side for the nerve if it is
trained on such a bias uh samples what
you'll end up is that on the side that's
unseen in the training set it looks
pretty blurry and you will see some
artifact in the background and it is
pretty severe
if you look at the ship scene but on the
other hand uh if we
use down nerf
on the other hand what you'll get is
that uh it can nicely render another
site thanks to the prior knowledge
injected by the pre-trained model like
clip
so here we can show that
our implementation is working
so lastly we would like to showcase our
demo shortly
and
it this demo is hosted by hugging face
bases is the latest platform released by
hacking face
uh essentially the purpose is to make
the machine learning deployment very
easy
uh with this platform you don't need to
maintain your own server you don't need
to write any docker container container
and what you need to do is just to open
up a repository in this counting phase
spaces and then you can keep pushing
your code and then they will do the
first version control for you
also you support automatic deployment
which means that you only need to
have your package
installation file also need to write
your file for file firing your
application your app
and then once you push your code they
will do the automatic deployment for you
so for time being i already navigate to
our demo so as you can see on the right
hand side is the rendering result by
dynaft
right now what you can see is the scene
this is the microphone scene
and it is trained on eight training
samples by dyna and on the left hand
side you can control the viewing post
for example uh for the first
for the first lighting bar you can
control the rotation on
horizontal axis
for example if i want to
fill this microphone
with some uh
anti-rotated anti-clockwise by some
degree uh wait a few minutes then you
will see the render result
so one thing to note is that um luckily
our platform is supported by um
by uh
[Music]
gpu devices so usually it takes uh quite
a long time to render
in this case yeah you see um right now
it is render result with only around 10
to 30 seconds
so as you can see uh this is a
microphone where you rotate clockwise by
some degree
and
yeah since we are supported by gpu
device it runs really fast but if you
are running in cpu it will take so much
time to render something like one to two
minutes the reason is because by time
you render you need to ask the nerf
model to render every pixel
and it is super expensive particularly
when you want to render a
full resolution image
and if you are interested in our
demo feel free to go through to our demo
play around on it
so lastly uh
we want to highlight one of the
myths that are still unable to address
essentially
for some experimental results we cannot
reproduce it
uh mainly on the
on the setting where
the nerve and nerve is trained on the
examples
uh in the paper we see that the nerve
really struggles on some an observed
region if you are training in such a
spark sample but what we get is that is
not as bad as the paper state
so you see that on the bottom is the
rendering result from us
having said that another site doesn't is
is looking blurry but it's not as bad as
state in the paper
so up here we still cannot
identify the reason yet
maybe it's because of the
compromise that we did in the
implementation i believe shion already
mentioned that
maybe it's because of the difference
between the python implementation and
the jackson orientation i believe for
the paper it is implemented in pi torch
for the nerve entire nerve
also it may also have something to do
with the hyperparameter that we choose
because the paper doesn't specify the
private parameter we need to
choose them by experiment then they have
other factors as well such as the wage
initialization and the samples that we
see left
up till now i will say
we still identify the reason yet
at last uh i would like to highlight our
work so if you want to get uh check out
our blog post
we have a blog post written in notion
which is shown in the right hand side uh
feel free to check it out we have uh lay
down a lot of model details or
implementation details also
uh the experience results there
also we have a demo which is shown in
taking phase basis
and if you want to check out our source
code feel free to go to a repository
if you'd like to repository feel free to
hit the start button
also we have archived our repository in
the papers with code
so lastly i would like to
very briefly highlight our next project
so essentially what we want to implement
next is text to 3dc
uh
we think that it is a super exciting
idea we see particularly this year there
is a lot of success
in text to 2d image generation for
example dali and also the dali mini
which is also one of the project in
in the jackson flex community week
but there's a limited research going on
on the text to 3d scene generation
so we are asking whether it is feasible
and
and recently we do see some evidence
that it is feasible
uh i will try to pick an example
that is posted that is tweeted by
eric drew essentially uh he
wrote a paper which is called evolving
evocative 2d views of generated 3d
objects
and it is featured in europe's
creativity and design workshop
so in the high level what what he's
doing is that to achieve the text to 3d
scene
he has he's coming up with a generator
which is the first component of the
system you have a generator the
generator is essentially a super formula
equation
so essentially super formula equation is
a equation which is pretty expressive
expressive enough to describe a lot of
3d shape
so
so once you have these uh
equations what you can do is you try to
tune its parameters uh for the super
formula there is 12 parameters and also
since it is a 3d surface you need to
render it into 2d snapshots so you need
to determine the filling post to
determine the filling pose you need
three additional parameters
so with this 15 parameters
the generator is composed of these 15
parameters
on the other hand once you have rendered
a 2d snapshot we need a second component
which is a scorer
[Music]
there are two alternatives for this
scorer firstly you can use a
pre-trained classification model
uh feed this 2d snapshot into this
pre-trained model and
evaluate the negative log likelihood
of its target class for example broccoli
or as an alternative you can also use
clip to achieve that essentially you are
trying to compare
the visual to this snapshot against the
caption the caption is essentially the
target class name for example the
broccoli
and since as the paper states that this
rendering from 3d surface to 2d snapshot
is not differentiable
so he's trying to apply a genetic
algorithm to optimize it what you will
end up is some really nice result as you
shown here
so
this is one piece of evidence showing
that text to 3d scene is indeed feasible
with the technology that we have
so
it gives us confidence that to give to
give it a try
so lastly uh we would like to give a big
thanks to
google teams and also hacking face for
organizing this very nice jackson flex
committee week
without this initiative i believe this
project won't exist
also a big thanks to common computer for
sponsoring us a
multi-gpu server
so i think that's all for presentation
awesome thanks for the presentation i
think it was great uh
before going to the questions let me
quickly share a bit of feedback from the
people
pedro cuenca says fantastic job
congratulations to the team
and they also appreciated that you
included a discussion about organization
and infra complexities
i think that this project in particular
was probably one of the
most technically challenging
projects from the whole sprint
especially given the timeline so for the
people that don't know like all of these
happen in a timeline of two
two weeks
maybe at most three weeks and this
this was like from organizing the team
uh deciding how to do the project and
learning about jacks having like talks
about jacks flags
and then
training the model and learning how to
do it with tpus uh
and finally creating a space to them of
the project so it really involves quite
a lot of things
and a lot of things to learn in a very
short time frame so i think that
it's a great achievement like for
anything that completely completed a
project it's already like a huge
achievement and this one in particular
it's very technically challenging so
congratulations on that
thank you
er also like for the people that want to
learn jazz i think that right now i like
shared some of the resources and right
now it's like a very good moment
compared to some months ago to learn
about jacks yeah so for from the first
sprint we had some talks
which are already shared weights and
biases is also organized in the study
group that alex mentioned there's like a
27 days of jax
thing kicking off today as well so there
are like many things going on
so i think december and if you are
having like
holidays like christmas holidays
in your countries or something like that
it's like a good moment to learn about
jax
also like some feedback from kalitis
that
stella and the team orchestrated the
whole project
so very well
we don't have that much time so let me
put some of the questions from the
people
and let me know if
yeah
so the first question from kiruka
is
how do you get raised and what is the
math behind it
i i'm not sure i understand the question
actually yeah
maybe i guess
how we
get the length
from the mathematical
theory so it is not the
mathematical
theory based just sampling some
distribution from the input image so lei
sampling is fully or random sampling and
so
you
yeah consider it
so maybe i add a few points so i think
for the light ray you can imagine
by the time we try to render a 3d
snapshot essentially like a camera
you're trying to render in front of the
viewer so what you can do is you can
associate each pixel to a light ray but
it is too expensive to
consider all the pixels so usually we do
a
core sampling
we have a sample range on it and once
you try to associate a light ray to a
pixel you can do a lightweight matching
what it's doing is that uh
from the viewer to this pixel you march
a light ray and then this pixel will
match through
the
this pixel through the 3d
and then through the vdc you can you can
start collecting the sample that uh that
is along this light ray so that's how it
works
i hope it helps
awesome thanks for the explanation
george says
congratulations awesome job
i wonder what your thoughts are on earth
compared to other image to image or b2b
with canon architectures
maybe i can comment a bit on this i i
think that the
net nerve is not to generate images it's
to generate 3d objects so in that sense
it's
much more complex compared to usual
image data so that means for example if
you've played a video game or if you use
unity 3d or like any game development
platform or with virtual reality
you don't have like images you have like
3d scenes that means that data is more
complicated you might have meshes for
example or point clouds depending on how
the data is represented
and so in that sense here you are not
generating a new image or a new video
you are generating like a full 3d object
i don't know if you guys have other
thoughts on that
yeah
are you go first instead uh yeah uh
program again
it is
normally used in 2d image
so far so
nerves
open some error to generate 3d
view view dependent uh
motor
yeah so it main difference is uh nerf
can generate some 3d uh
view dependent uh
motor that nerf can generate
that 3d depend beauty dependent model
and again
make some
2d
many 2d generation
yeah
to add a few more points so essentially
what nerf is learning is not an image
what it's learning is a
representation of the 3d scene
uh so what you see is you can imagine
what nerf is learning is is actually a
volume uh when you try to query a point
in this volume the enough will tell you
what is the color and the
uh
opacity of this point so with this rich
kind of representation you are trying to
you can use this representation to
render different
different 2d snapshots from whatever
angle you want
awesome thanks
let's go for one last question and there
were like few other
missing questions so i think it would be
great if
we can
if you have some time to answer them
later on in discord and also like share
some of the resources that you shared
so let me quickly go to the last one
from james barry the question is
were any parts of the project difficult
when dealing with functions which do not
which do not have a side effects
yeah i think
i think because there's no side effect
particularly on the part that you want
to cheat or you want to apply the
function transformation it makes
it will make the structure pretty
unintuitive and pretty different from
what you write in python tensorflow
in the way that in in tensorflow python
you have a trainer
you will wrap everything into this
trainer and then you have different
associate method
but in some some case uh it is this kind
of state is not supported in jack so in
some cases you need to slightly rewrite
them
i know one side effect objects
in case of tensorflow or python they can
use
i mean
in the distributed learning
hydrogen tensorflow can use different
best size for each gpu for example gp1
has 64 images and gpu one http 2 has
maybe 32 images but in case of jacks
just have to
distribute the image equally i mean
because it
just uh
chart the data using tensor reshape so
it should
be it should distribute the image
equally for each gpu i think it is the
minor minor thing but
i think it is the side effects
anyway
awesome
okay thanks guys for this people were
super happy
yeah everyone is saying congratulations
in the chat uh
so anyways thanks everyone for joining
us see you in discord for the remaining
questions in the next couple of hours uh
feel free to keep asking questions in
the next couple of days and feel free
also to to follow
the theme in twitter they share like
very interesting things and the
next projects will be also quite
interesting
so yeah thanks a lot for joining and
beautiful
guys
and thanks so much for organizing this
talk over
for sure thanks a lot